un tsunami golpeó nukualofa la capital
de tonga en todo el archipiélago los
habitantes fueron evacuados de las
costas desde el viernes debido a varias
erupciones de un volcán en una isla
deshabitada gonzález
[Música]
a 65 km de la capital se encuentra en un
gato hunga ha'apai el estruendo se
escuchó hasta fiji a más de 800
kilómetros de distancia la columna de
humo visible desde el espacio alcanzó
los 20 kilómetros de altura en una
erupción submarina cuando es poco
profunda el contacto agua magma es muy
explosivo la gente piensa que el agua
apagará el volcán pero es lo contrario
el agua se vaporiza y aumenta la
explosividad del conjunto por lo que
tenemos erupciones muy violentas esto
fue suficiente para preocupar a los
servicios de alerta de samoa americana
que activaron los protocolos de
emergencia así como en los territorios
de ultramar franceses de wallis y futuna
estamos emitiendo una alerta de tsunami
para samur por favor resguardados en
terrenos más altos
las autoridades de fiyi aconsejaron a la
población que protegerán las reservas de
agua dulce de lluvia ácida y de las
cenizas mientras que nueva zelanda
monitorea el nivel de las aguas de sus
costas orientales ante la posibilidad de
que aumente la marea